colton underwood has got a lot of
criticism over his coming out
including how he's now shooting a
netflix show about his journey
yeah but um in his recent interview with
variety colton says
that part of the reason he wanted uh to
be a role model for athletes
he recalls seeing nfl player michael sam
come out in 2014
and that almost inspired colton to do
the same
yeah colton tells the magazine i've had
a conversation with michael about this
since i came out
i just sort of had a heart to heart with
him i said i just want to let you know
that you should have
you should have given me the confidence
to stand up and say you're not alone
but unfortunately i was in a different
locker room and i told him in the locker
room that i was in
they didn't say nice things about you i
was like i'm sorry because i could have
tried to help you by coming out with you
and then seeing if that caused another
to come out but i didn't have the
courage
and i wasn't at a point in my life where
i was ready to come out if anything
michael sam coming out and being so
public about it put me in the closet
even further
because i didn't want to be like michael
in the sense that i didn't want to
be negative or bad the football in the
athletic community is not ready for gay
people
and here's what colton really felt the
lack of representation when he was
growing up
we had one gay guy in my entire town and
at the time
he was sort of the butt of every joke
especially in the locker room and
especially on the football field and it
was never a good thing it was never a
cool thing
i would have done anything to have
a professional football player in the
nfl
so that i could have looked and been
like i want to be like him
and i just didn't didn't have that we
didn't have that we still don't i didn't
want to be a role model but i don't have
a choice because
while people are coming out saying
we don't need another white man coming
out we've heard this story before
i'm here to tell you i grew up in
central illinois and as an athlete
as football players specifically i
didn't have representation
and i know that there's far more
representation than just who i am
physically but also in the industry and
in the community
and there's so many different levels
that we can do better and help support
one another and that's what i want to do
yes samantha says man that's so sad
edward says i knew he was getting
colton's story seems so calculated
uh tony says oh there was more than one
gay gay guy in your town trust me that's
the thing
yeah we've talked about this a lot in
the show about like often when we talk
about someone coming out there's
comments of
oh why are we still talking with
someone's sexuality you know it doesn't
matter anymore but i mean it still
very much matters especially in the
sports world
yeah i i i think we need to keep talking
about it
i think that if there's one young person
who's watching this live today
and is in a small town like the one i
grew up in
you know that matters this conversation
matters it's a seed that
is planted i also think that in
in gym class in sports these things need
to be talked about i think that it
really needs to start at the younger
levels
um you know of the rep teams i think it
needs to be discussed i think
it needs to be you know considered all
of it
um it's not just up at the nfl or in the
hockey leagues like in the nhl
it needs to start at a very young age
kids need support
yeah pulsar says gay men are everywhere
i'm sure they're in sports it's
improbable that no gay people are
in professional sports it's impossible
but that's the thing like yeah we
haven't had
old athletes and yeah it's still a thing
like i think people
people that are very accepting like
straight people are very accepting think
like yeah it's not a big deal but yeah
like you said like you think about the
small towns where it's just not talked
about that much and
especially in the media world like media
world yeah it tends to be very open and
there's a lot of gay people in it but
yeah when you go to small towns it's
just not talked about and so i think
it's so important that people
still keep coming out and still
acknowledge your sexuality and yes
hopefully one day it won't matter but
we're not in that place at all it's
still very much matters and yeah the
sports world i mean
we don't have those we're getting some
but yeah we don't have those role models
there
i don't like i remember even the we
talked about keith winslet
uh probably a month ago she was saying
she knows like several high-profile
actors
that are gay but won't come out of the
closet because they think it's gonna
hurt their career so
it's still very much a thing that yeah
and and yeah i mean still people still
get beat up for being gay stuff like
that and
like colton was talking about that
locker room culture that you can't come
out of the closet so
it's still very much an issue so i think
it's something we still need to talk
about even if people get
whatever bored by hearing about it some
people get bored by hearing about it but
it absolutely still matters that's the
thing graham too i think that if someone
is writing a comment or saying something
like
we've talked about this enough or this
is enough that's the problem
that's the problem right there the fact
that you think it's enough
that's a problem we need to keep talking
about it and you should be comfortable
enough to hear it over
and over and over again and when you get
comfortable with that
then we're making progress people
talking about their feelings and their
emotions
and how they feel they fit into society
is really important and so i think we
need to continue that conversation from
the youngest
ages to to the to the top
yeah mommy says people need to get a
grip and show some compassion
yeah adversaries are still big time
homophobia mostly among men especially
in uh
in sports uh ai says coming out should
always be okay yeah it shouldn't and so
hopefully
yeah all these stories are helping but
yeah even someone in the top of
hollywood still feels nervous about
coming out of the closet so
yeah it's still something we need to
discuss so yeah i i know colton is
problematic i know like there's all the
issues with cassie that
the the restraining order stuff like
that like i know colton's
like not a perfect person yeah clinton's
not a perfect person but
yeah i think you look at his everything
that's happened with him and i think
where
a lot of people get stuck especially
women is the part where it was the
restraining order and the stalking
because that's scary and so that's
i it's a whole issue in itself it's
something else and it
takes away from what this conversation
is